[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
jacqueline gourault bonjour bonjour
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous ministre
de la cohésion des territoires et des
relations avec les collectivités
territoriales
on est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour
une interview en partenariat avec la
presse quotidienne régionale représenté
par florent buisson journalistes à la
république du centre
bonjour votre gestion du coup jacqueline
gourault on va en parler tout à l'heure
on commence bien sûr par ce discours de
politique générale et jean castex qui a
beaucoup mis en avant son bon sens le
bon sens durant son discours
est-ce qu'il doit philippe manqué de bon
sens oulala je ne vais pas comparer
l'ancien et le nouveau premier ministre
chacun a son style est en tout cas le
discours de jean castex hier a montré
que nous avons un premier ministre qui
est concret qui veut avancer sur des
objectifs non pas il faille nombre à bhl
mais sur quelques objectifs
rappelant que nous sommes en période de
crise et que nous il nous reste six
cents jours avant la fin du mandat du
président de la république
donc c'est quelqu'un de concret et qui
veut avancer sur les territoires le mot
territoire a été prononcée à de
nombreuses reprises on va en parler mais
son discours en parler mais jean castex
a remplacé les doigts fait pour une
question de méthode
en tout cas c'est ce qu'on a compris de
la part d' emmanuel macron y avait un
problème avec la méthode est ce que
celle qui a été décliné hier par jean
castex et la bonne est meilleure en tout
cas jean castex et est à la fois comme
vous le savez un élu local qui a occupé
toutes les strates je dirais des
collectivités territoriales jusqu'à sa
nomination il était maire président de
communauté de communes et conseiller
général
il connaît bien les collectivités
locales
il a sont comment dire ses origines du
sud-ouest qui s'entendent à son accent
fonctionnaires et c'est aussi un haut
fonctionnaire qui connaît bien la
fonction publique c'est pas quelque
chose car en avant contrairement aux
territoires est ce que c'est quand il la
réponse
des rafales de leur rappelle tous les
postes qu'il a occupés et je crois que
d'être un premier ministre issu de la
technocratie que comme on dit alors
qu'on veut justement mettre de l'huile
un peu dans les rouages
est-ce que vous attend c'est qu'il a
l'air d'un technocrate franchement non
mais c'est trop tard hier ça n'est pas
tout à fait l'image qu'il renvoie et
c'est très bien parce que ça montre que
aussi dans la haute fonction publique il
y à des hommes de ce tempérament de 7,2
ce caractère et je crois que partout où
il est passé en tout cas les hommes
politiques avec lesquels il a travaillé
en disent tous du bien et je crois comme
il le dit lui-même que bien connaître la
fonction au public c'est un atout aussi
pour lui en tant que responsable
politique parce que ça lui permet d'en
voir
je dirais les avantages et les
inconvénients alors justement il a parlé
de l'armement rien de réarmer les les
territoires c'est une phrase forte pour
premier ministre d'un président à qui
l'on a parfois reproché de les délaisser
ces territoires
alors at il fallu les gilet jaune et la
crise du coc vide pour que l'exécutif
comprennent que certains territoires
étaient délaissées voir sacrifié écoutez
moi je suis ministre pas tout à fait
depuis le premier jour mais presque
et j'ai toujours été sur ce portefeuille
que ce soit auprès de gérard collomb à
beauvau où depuis deux ans
au ministère de la cohésion des
territoires et des relations avec les
collectivités territoriales et nous
avons toujours beaucoup travaillé avec
les territoires et pour les territoires
alors il y a eu peut-être aussi parce
que vous savez quand on se parle il faut
toujours être deux il y a eu aussi
peut-être des comment dire des attitudes
ou voir des postures politiques
vis-à-vis du président de la république
qui avait un parcours qui n'était pas le
même que beaucoup d'autres c'est à dire
qu'il n'avait pas été un élu local et
c'est quelque chose qui lui a été
reprochée d'emblée mais on peut pas
reprocher à quelques ces crises ont aidé
à se rendre compte de l'importance
justement des territoires comme la prise
de conscience comme la crise des gilet
jaune le président de la république
l'avait dit lui même mais je vous
rappelle aussi le grand débat qu'il a
initié et c'est lui qui est allé au
charbon si je puis dire
le grand ses bras à il est quelque chose
de très très important c'est des
complicités sur le fait que c'était le
fait que ces dépôts sur vous visez
territoire unis on n'imagine pas parce
que moi j'ai toujours eu des relations
je dirais cordiales avec les
associations d'élus mais force est de
constater que la création de territoire
unis s'étaient pas la création d'un club
d'amitié pour le président de la
république c'était un club dira le
président du sénat et les autres
représentants pour défendre les
collectivités locales soit mais parfois
il y a eu dans le regard porté sur le
gouvernement et sur le président de la
république
des positions qui tenait parfois de la
posture mais quand françois baroin
encore la semaine dernière indique
emmanuel mac on ne les entend pas que
l'état est hyper centralisé qu'il
travaille en silo est ce qu'il n'ya pas
du vrai et bien c'est la preuve que il y
a une espèce de fond qui a été adoptée
et qui a du mal à évoluer
malgré tout les politiques publiques qui
sont mises en place
soyons concret je ne sais pas l'agenda
rural
je suppose que françois baroin est
conscient de ce que nous faisons pour la
ruralité qui n'a jamais été fait
deuxièmement sur le plan financier pour
les collectivités territoriales
vous savez que nous avons maintenu les
dotations de fonctionnement pour les
collectivités territoriales et qu'on n'a
jamais mis autant d'argent pour
l'investissement pour les sur les
collectivités territoriales
encore récemment nous avons annoncé un
milliard supplémentaire de des cils
c'est-à-dire de financement pour des
investissements pour les collectivités
territoriales
c'est donc des choses qui sont très
importantes et nous avez entendu andré
la semaine dernière andré lunel qui
préside le comité des finances locales
dire que ces moyens sont trop fléchier
qui a pas assez d'autonomie pour les
collectivités territoriales sur ces
moyens est ce que vous allez changer ça
non mais y'a les ressources des
collectivités territoriales est ce que
l'état apporte pourrait aider les
projets des collectivités territoriales
d'ailleurs on ne le fait pas que sur le
plan financier on le fait sur le plan
aussi de l'ingénierie avec la création
de l'agencé nationale de cohésion des
territoires et nous avons des politiques
publiques qui s'appliquent sur
l'ensemble du territoire
je vais prendre par exemple action coeur
de ville pour 222 villes moyennes en
france qui est un grand succès les
maires des 222 ville sont extrêmement
positifs sur cette politique et c'est du
concret avec des projets en plus qui
partent du bas de la volonté des élus on
respecte la volonté des élus on les aide
à mettre en place et nous allons bientôt
avec le premier ministre
l'ansés petite ville de demain qui va
cibler des villes qui font centralité
dans les territoires français et qu'ils
sont moins de 20000 habitants mais
parfois mais aussi à cette démarche
oui bien sûr souvent ce qu'ils dénoncent
des preuves des programmes qui sont
lancées à l'échelle de l'état
nous avons sans le lien avec les élus
locaux et bien je ne sais pas invité par
exemple le président
des petites villes de france il vous
dira tout le travail qui a été fait en
partenariat pour construire petite ville
de demain les amis qui décident et les
collectivités qui exécutent n'en ai
aussi l'association des maires ruraux de
france d'ailleurs petite ville de demain
et dans l'agenda rural et l'idée c'est
qu'il ya des projets locaux et que
l'état vient en soutien des projets
locaux et vous savez toutes les
politiques
utilisons le nom de contractualisation
c'est quelque chose qui marche
hier je discutais avec une député de la
nièvre qui me parlait du contrat que
nous avons signé avec le département de
la nièvre qui est très avancé avec des
exécutions importantes sur des projets
qui étaient des projets locaux
parce qu'on parle des finances locales
est ce que vous pouvez nous éclairer sur
la taxe d'habitation est ce que les 20%
des français qui payent encore cette
taxe d'habitation vont continuer à la
payer jusqu'à quand alors peut-être
rappeler aux français que en sept années
2020 80% des ménages ne perd plus de
taxe d'habitation et qu'il reste 20 %
des français qui vont qui normalement la
paix jusqu'en 2023
le président de la république a évoqué
cela comme une hypothèse une réflexion
voir si le comment dire l'échéance
serait reculer ou pas il ne s'agit pas
de créer un impôt supplémentaire ou quoi
que ce soit il s'agit d'un d'une baisse
de prix mais en un local andré jean moi
c'est un non un impôt qui est supprimé
la taxe d'habitation est supprimée sur
les résidences principales
je rappelle qu'il est maintenue sur les
résidences secondaires et alors pour les
20 % de français qui nous écoutent et
qui la paye qu'est ce que vous leur
dites ce matin jusqu'à que je leur dise
ce qu'a dit le premier le pardon que le
président de la république le
gouvernement va en discuter va évaluer
si c'est quelque chose qui est utile
dans une période où il faut faire aussi
attention à la gestion des finances
publiques parce que il faut à la fois
répondre
à ceux qui sont beaucoup touché par la
crise c'est-à-dire le savez que la
priorité est le premier ministre l'a
suffisamment d'hier et vous l'avez
rappelé avec le titre des dernières
nouvelles d'alsace c'est de lutter
contre le chômage et donc il faut voir
quelles sont les priorités nous allons
regarder cela de près mais ça veut dire
décalé décalé où ça veut dire supprimer
peut-être que les vents la taxe
d'habitation ignorons la place on va
être supprimée savoure tout le monde
s'est certes pour tout le monde
d'ailleurs c'est juste que je veux
défendre et bien sûr ces constitutions
raison je vous rappelle à mais c'est ça
qu'il faut discuter c'est exactement ça
d'accord mais je rappelle que le sens
institutionnel à vide
excusez moi je me rappelle que le
conseil constitutionnel avait demandé au
gouvernement d'alors de détendre
l'ensemble de cette suppression de la
taxe d'habitation à l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens
au nom d'un principe constitutionnel qui
est l'égalité devant l'impôt
allez on va parler de la
décentralisation a notamment de votre la
3d ça fait quand même des années qu'on
parle de décentralisation que les élus
attendent un nouveau souffle d'un
nouveau souffle de décentralisation bien
avant la crise sanitaire est ce que vous
pouvez leur garantir ce matin qu'il y
aura un véritable acte de
décentralisation d'ici la fin du
quinquennat
oui puisque le premier ministre l'a dit
hier absolument clairement et la
décentralisation nous sommes dans une
république décentralisée il faut
toujours le rappeler c'est mam est
inscrit là aussi dans la constitution
ce nouveau souffle et fleurs nouvel acte
telle qu'on a connus sous gaston
defferre ou sous jean-pierre raffarin
oui on les deux précédents alors où est
ce que ça ne va pas aussi loin moi je je
je veux toujours c'est pas un mouvement
perpétuel
je le dis comme ça très simplement la
décentralisation
parce que il y à des domaines et je
crois que les français sont tous
attachés à cela qu'ils sont comme on dit
du régalien
c'est à dire la justice la police la
santé tous à la protection sociale c'est
du régalien et les français ils sont
très attachés
donc on va pas
jusqu'à la fin des temps parler de
décentralisation ce qui un jour je
dirais la ressource manquera je ne sais
pas comment le dire plus simplement
mais tout le monde sait qu'il y a besoin
de clarifier un certain nombre de
compétences qu'il y a des trous dans la
raquette comme on dit aujourd'hui sur
des compétences on sait pas très bien
qui les exercent
il ya des compétences qu'on pense il
serait mieux exercer au plus près du
territoire que ça ne l'est aujourd'hui
le président de la république a lui-même
dit devant les associations d'élus dans
des réunions auxquelles j'assistais que
par exemple sur le logement
il était prêt à faire une
décentralisation
vers les collectivités territoriales
donc il y a plusieurs thèmes comme cela
on parle aujourd'hui de la réification
en panne d'efficacité non oui mais il ya
aussi des des comment dire des
décentralisations qui sont à poursuivre
je vais prendre un autre exemple il y a
des départements qui demandent à avoir
des routes qui sont aujourd'hui rester
nationale
eh bien on dit ben pourquoi pas jeudi
certains départements parce que ça n'est
pas vrai de tous les départements et
c'est là où aussi intervient une autre
notion qui est au fond la
différenciation c'est accepter que l'on
puisse décentralisée des routes avec tel
ou tel département et que nous ne le
fassions pas pour des raisons
voilà qui tiennent à la fois à l'intérêt
départementale et à l'intérêt national
de ne pas les décentraliser ses être
pragmatique avoir du bon sens et ce qui
aura un effort sur la communication
aussi auprès des français pour qu'ils
comprennent mieux cette architecture
territoriale aujourd'hui clairement
quand on parle aux gens n'y comprennent
absolument rien les métropoles les
départements les communautés de communes
les régions l'europe c'est très
compliqué à appréhender est ce qu'il ya
un effort à faire là dessus
sûrement il ya toujours des et faire des
efforts de communication à faire
je crois que les français recherchent
l'efficacité des politiques publiques et
ce qu'ils veulent c'est que les gens
comment dire se serre la main et enfin
ce travail ensemble c'est ça que je veux
dire et en même temps qu'il y ait un
accès facile aux politiques publiques
c'est la raison pour laquelle est le
premier ministre en a parlé aussi il y à
la manière dont sont organisés les
pouvoirs publics sur les territoires
parce que quand on dit les territoires
et je sais ce que pense le premier
ministre sur les territoires il ya
l'action des collectivités territoriales
et ce qui est fondamental mais sur les
territoires il y à aussi l'action de
l'état ce qu'on appelle l'action afin dé
l'état déconcentré et ça c'est quelque
chose qui auquel tient beaucoup
le premier ministre avec une ligne de
force qui est le renforcement de
l'échelon départemental pour la présence
de l'état sur les territoires avec ça va
contribuer à faciliter la vie des
français la vie quotidienne j'entends
parce que vous avez des guichet unique
des endroits où il ya l'état qui est
représenté et qui représente l'ensemble
des représentants de l'état sur les
territoires et c'est quelque chose qui
facilite les choses
vous travaillez sur une grande motte
décentralisation à qu'on a appelé la loi
3 des différentes stations des
concentrations décentralisation est ce
qu'elle est encore d'actualité cette loi
on en est où
mais elle est totalement d'actualité
d'ailleurs là on vient de parler du
troisième des si je puis dire qui est
très important on a parlé avant de
décentralisation de compétences qui
peuvent être transférées aux
collectivités territoriales et puis il y
à la différenciation et vous savez que
la différenciation était un projet de la
réforme constitutionnelle
la réforme constitutionnelle n'a pas pu
avoir lieu
nous sommes ici au sénat je veux pas
vous faire de dessin n'a pas pu avoir
lieu mais nous avons je dirais trouver
le mois le moyen d'avancer sur ce sujet
par le fait de comment dire déposé
récemment au conseil d'état un projet de
loi organique sur l'expérimentation et
au fond l'expérimentation qui va donc
évoluer je vais revenir si vous voulez
bien va nous permettre d'avancer vers la
différenciation
qu'est ce qu'on propose d'abord il faut
rappeler que c'est à la suite d'une
commande du premier ministre edouard
philippe au conseil d'état sur une
réflexion qui a été fait par le conseil
d'état sur la manière de faire de
l'expérimentation et ce rapport nous a
enfin été très positif est au fond le pg
lo que nous avons déposé il ya deux
idées fortes
sans entrer dans le détail première idée
il faut faciliter
accès à l'expérimentation que le chemin
soit beaucoup plus simple éviter tous
les décrets qui vont bien et cetera
simplifiée et la deuxième chose sortir
du caractère binaire de
l'expérimentation
qu'est ce que cela veut dire cela veut
dire que aujourd'hui quand vous faites
une expérimentation au bout d'un certain
nombre d'années
si elle veut se poursuivre il faut
qu'elle s'étende à l'ensemble du
territoire
ou alors on est obligé de l'arrêter donc
il faut sortir de ce caractère binaire
pour que l'expérimentation puisse
devenir définitives sur certains
territoires sans s'étendre sur
l'ensemble du territoire français mais
du coup concrètement votre la 3d elle
sera divisée en plusieurs lois ou est-ce
que ça restera un ensemble présenté en
conseil des ministres et dans ces cas là
quand ben là c'est un projet de loi
organique
d'ailleurs mais le stress du mra ça où
il y aura peut être améliorée bien sûr
un autre projet de loi dont par les
différents programmes symphoniques on
doit unique voilà
abbas et a toujours été prévu comme ça
est-ce que l'organe xl organique
ce qui relève de la constitution c'est
ce qu'ils monnayent le reste ça sera
beaucoup plus tard annoncé pas que ce
sera beaucoup plus tard le reste va
venir je dirais dans le dans leur
complémentarité du projet de loi
organique bien évidemment un mot sur la
conférence nationale des territoires
dans son interview à la presse
quotidienne régionale emmanuel macron
dit espérer une nouvelle conférence
nationale de taille portes d'ici l'été
est ce qu'elle est déjà prévue il va y
avoir une réunion des conférences la
conférence nationale du territoire
simplement nous sommes en train de
réfléchir avec les associations d'élus
pour essayer de trouver la formule qui
soit là aussi la plus efficace possible
parce que les grandes messes
on a vu on a expérimenté au début du
mandat
on a vu aussi que un certain nombre
d'associations boycotter la conférence
nationale des territoires donc on va
essayer de mettre sur pied une méthode
nouvelle pour que trop chacun y trouve
son compte si je puis dire
donc ça n'est pas d'ici l'été de façon
pragmatique c'est le premier ministre
qui en décidera d'ici les régionales
quand même ah bah oui les régionales
c'est c'est loin
l'été s'est vite quand même il reste
deux trois semaines on imagine que ce à
quoi nous sommes écoutés
le premier miss a déjà reçu toutes les
associations d'élus mais ces arguments
et je rappeler quand il a été nommé
elle aura lieu à la fin juillet cette
conférence nationale des territoires je
sais le premier ni ce qu'il annoncera
est juste un mot sur ce qu'ils avaient
fait pschitt notamment cette histoire du
pack de cahors de contractualisation de
limiter la hausse des dépenses est ce
que ça c'est fini maintenant
alors vous savez que c'est déjà suspendu
ses suspendus et remis alors nous allons
à le pas du tout là aussi ça fait partie
du travail
on ne peut pas dire il faut dialoguer
avec les collectivités territoriales et
que moi tout seul sans qu'il y ait les
réunions avec les associations et le
premier ministe de prendre cette
décision mais naturellement on voit bien
que fameux prudente sur la question
vous avez coupé à portes on voit bien
que les circonstances dans lesquelles
nous sommes sans plus tôt et je me
permets de le faire remarquer un état
qui aide les collectivités territoriales
parce que tout le monde oublie mais nous
savons que nous venons de répondre aux
difficultés d'un certain nombre de
communes et des intercommunalités en
compensant les pertes de recettes ce qui
est très important en faisant des
avances remboursables pour les
départements et bien sûr nous allons
continuer à accompagner les
collectivités territoriales dans cette
crise et naturellement ce qui était vrai
dans une période où on commençait à
retrouver à l'horizon positif n'est pas
forcément vrai dans une période de crise
c'est ça être concret et répondre à
l'actualité
un dernier mot rapidement les occire
avant l'instant ça florent pour une
question si cette génération gaulle
juste le sénat a fait 50 propositions
sur la décentralisation il y a dix jours
notamment sur l'autonomie financière sur
la garantir la place de la commune est
ce que vous allez reprendre ses
propositions
c'est enfin je reprends simplement
l'autonomie financière voyez que c'est
un débat sur lesquels il faut beaucoup
discuté parce que quand il ya des crises
comme nous venons d'en vivre
quand même les collectivités
territoriales se tourner immédiatement
vers l'état pour avoir des compensations
donc vous savez je suis intimement
convaincu que la france est comment dire
un pays où la subtilité
des missions entre les collectivités
territoriales et l'état doit être encore
largement discuté parce que dans une
france décentralisée laquelle nous nous
sommes avec des gens qui s'accuse d'être
girondins ou ja coma je crois qu'il faut
savoir que les français n'est ce pas m
des collectivités qui assument leurs
responsabilités et qu'ils aiment aussi
un état garderie qu'elle serait pas
repris de gare en gare en attendait non
c'est pas du tout j'ai pas répondu
garant de l'équité des territoires et
des populations
naturellement il y a plein de
propositions dans ce café le sénat sur
lequel nous sommes d'accord depuis très
longtemps donc je vais pas vous dire le
contraire
madame les miss vous êtes vous êtes élus
de la région centre les régionales sont
prévues dans huit mois vous dites que
c'est loin mais ça se prépare dès
aujourd'hui évidemment et ce qu'il faut
que votre collègue ministre modem marc
fesneau conduise la liste de la majorité
présidentielle pour ce scrutin
dans la région centre évidemment eh bien
écoutez c'est à lui qu'il faudra à poser
la question qu'est ce que personnel
naturellement vous savez j'ai été tête
de liste aux régionales marc fesneau l'a
déjà été
nous sommes très attachés à notre région
centre val de loire et naturellement
d'une manière ou d'une autre nous
participerons à cette campagne
l'aïd el fitr isolé m on verra les
circonstances du moment vous serez
impliqué vous à ben bien sûr que je
serai impliqué sur le net
je ne sais pas comment je dis oui je
serai impliqué après je ne sais pas
comment
merci beaucoup merci florent merci
jacqueline gourault demain justement
votre tasse et marc fesneau
le ministre est cyclique et chargé des
relations avec le parlement et de la
participation citoyenne on lui posera
ans elle est obligée de rester ici
merci merci d'avoir été avec nous gérons
pas ce site au club des territoires